on a remarqué qu'un grand nombre de
stars de la télé réalité ont pris la
décision d'aller s'installer à dubaï
tous regardent une bonne idée il ya
comme qui dirait une nouvelle mode qui
souffle chez les stars de télé réalité
elles sont de plus en plus nombreux à
les installer à dubaï
ap
[Musique]
après les marseillais thibault et
jessica qui nous bombarde de vidéos sur
leur nouvelle ville a jasé laurent des
anges saison 8 honteux aussi déménager
ils en ont assez des cambriolages
bienvenue à dubaï ici pas de voleur pas
de voyeurisme pas d'agression pas d'
insulte avec en prime le soleil toute
l'année le désert et le luxe vous les
comprenez vous
[Musique]
le sun internet du vafc qui a pas
d'impôt pour atteindre n'importe quoi
violet et pas sur un stade toute la
journée laure muller rolex laurent
maucort leur pognon il serait pas
braquer avec la d'accord il avait réduit
et bien sûr les souterrains tout montrer
achevé leur vie de leur rue de leur
maison de leur appartient à un moment
donné ou faux pas ce faux-pas scrog faut
pas se plaint pas de s'étonner si ba oui
bah c'est pas pour ça c'est pour autre
chose monsieur déconner vous connaissez
une personne une personne qui a été
cambriolée qui change totalement de pays
qui paraît existe oui je comprends
beaucoup dubaï aussi c'est très beau
c'est bling bling c'est tout ce qu'on
veut il ya beaucoup d'argent à dubaï
maintenant voilà pour une des petites
histoires aussi deux garçons questionne
âme à la bassée direct la prison un
maître dans l'art de leur dire un petit
peu aussi ce que c'est que le l'émirat
il ya eu cinq cambriolages quand même
autour de jambes de la télé réalité une
tentative de braquage c'est vous qui
prenez tu prenais les plaintes ou pas
braquage par arme à feu
donc quand même ils sont repérés parce
qu'ils sont géolocalisées a que ça
risque sakoba ça à cause de viril comme
les footballeurs à marseille par exemple
qui sont victimes cambrai là ce sont les
nouvelles cibles
donc on peut comprendre aussi que c'est
on peut comprendre aussi que certains
agresser ou à louer à miami jamais dans
les villes et plus culturel